no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory
there's a lot of moms and dads out there
who are democrats are on the fence who
are saying i certainly hope they
wouldn't mandate that no no look what
i'm saying is that i don't think you can
mandate it but you can't say everyone
has to do this but you would just like
you can't mandate a mask this summer we
made progress through the combination of
vaccine requirements and incentives as
well as the fda approval
four million more people got their first
shot in august than they did in july
but we need to do more
this is not about freedom or personal
choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
what up yo i'm dave rubin it's june 22nd
2022 this is the reuben report we are
live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv if you have not subscribed
already just do it already what are you
waiting for and actually of all days to
do it do it today june 22nd because as i
just told the guys my due date was june
22nd 1976. i stayed in stewing in the
juices till june 26th so my birthday is
this sunday but it's a special day
because it was my due date i don't think
they let babies stay in
anymore after the nine months after the
due date they get them out pretty quick
these days back then you're allowed to
stay in anyway subscribe if you haven't
quick reminder july 14th miami i'm in
you
that's right i'm at the miami improv on
july 14th with at least one special
guest from the miami area you can get
tickets at daverubin.com
events we did open up 50 extra vip
tickets if you want the one second hug
and as for today's show if you're
wondering why we showed you those old
videos that little compilation there of
the elderly gentleman pretending to be
president joseph r biden
it's because they seem to want to bring
back kovid because you see things are
not going well for these people they've
destroyed the economy we have the half
war three-quarter war maybe full war
going on with russia and ukraine uh gas
prices
supply chain all the problems nobody's
happy everybody realizes he has dementia
the wheels are coming off this thing
uh so joe biden basically said it
yesterday yeah they're bringing back
kovid and not only they bring them back
kovid but they want you to jab your
babies too these people are psychopaths
absolute psychopaths
but as you know
i believe there are markers for a
turnaround i believe good people are
waking up and we're going to talk about
how to fight the lunacy because the
lunacy is coming oh and a quick reminder
starting yesterday
we will now at the end of the show where
i always read the locals comments so the
locals community
reubenreport.locals.com which you can
get on the ios app or on android or just
on desktop we read comments from the
community throughout the show and during
the day every single day i respond to
people on there it's the only place i
respond to people
but starting yesterday and going forward
we will also read rumble rant so if
you're watching right now the live
stream on rumble and you do a paid
rumble rant we'll also read a couple of
those before we get to the big show
people let me talk to you about real
estate agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my good buddy glenn beck they
work with only the best agents in every
market they do their homework they talk
to every agent before inviting them to
their network and here's a big one they
only work with full-time professionals
no part-time or inexperienced agents
their team makes the intro then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied they work with agents that
have long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
including the free state of florida just
go to real estate agents itrust.com
today and provide them with some basic
info their team will contact you to make
an introduction to their preferred agent
in your town and then you can be living
next door to me right here in miami all
right here we go so
the big thing over the last two days
they're always trying to keep our eye
off the ball right they don't want you
looking at the gas prices they don't
want you looking at the stock stock
market they don't want you looking and
seeing that your 401k is down they don't
want you seeing that joe biden can't
complete a sentence so covid has somehow
snuck back into the thing it is in the
system again people are talking about it
again and the c
d
c the center for disease control which
has botched everything either through
complete negligence or total ineptitude
or perhaps intentional who the hell
knows at this point
they are now endorsing
babies babies
babies getting the jab here is a tweet
from cdc director rochelle walensky we
haven't talked about her in quite some
time today i endorsed akip's
recommendation that all children
six months through five years of age
should receive a covid19 vaccine parents
i strongly encourage you to get your
children vaccinated against covid19 and
then she links of course to the cdc
tweet on this now
i'm not even going to get into the
numbers right it does not even matter at
this point you guys know it you know it
and i don't want to bludgeon you with
numbers
this
virus barely affected children it's not
one percent it's not one percent of one
percent it's significantly less than
that and the ones that it did had all
sorts of other uh health problems that's
number one number two you should be very
very skeptical of anything these people
uh want you to do at this point the
people who got you fired from your jobs
or mandated this or that or wanted you
in masks that don't work or anything
else or vaccines that ended up not
working as promised how many times do i
have to show you videos or have you seen
the videos of fauci saying if you get
vaccinated you're good to go biden if
you get vaccinated you won't get or
transmit covet they've lied about
everything these companies are also not
being held legally responsible for any
side effects and they don't have to open
up their books on this stuff for 75
years as i mentioned on the show
yesterday if you take advil it tells you
all the side effects if you take any
medication every commercial that you
watch on television for any problem that
you have the half the commercial is a
list of side effects diarrhea vomiting
thoughts of suicide blah blah blah but
we're not talking about any of those
things related to this and now they want
to inject six-month-olds i can tell you
as i said yesterday as a father-to-be it
will be over my dead body that my
children will be injected with whatever
the hell this thing is even if at this
point they could say to me oh no it has
no side effects
children simply do not need it little
babies do not need it so anyway rachelle
wilinsky who has been an absolute fraud
this entire time from the cdc she
tweeted that out it got about a thousand
likes now i don't want to pat myself on
the back but i'm gonna do it pull up my
tweet
i retweeted her and i wrote you should
be in jail i thought i just cut right to
it you know what i mean it got 35 000
likes so she got 1 000 likes on her
tweet about jabbing babies i'm just some
guy you know what i mean like yeah you
know i got a youtube show and put on a
jacket every day a little hairspray i'm
doing all right but the point is
nobody's paying attention to these
people the head of the cdc if we were
all so concerned oh my god it's so great
we're to jab all the babies click like
on this thing
nobody's paying attention to these
people and nobody should pay attention
to these people
and why should they not pay attention to
these people because jabbing babies it's
not even being studied properly there is
no evidence that any of this works uh
rand paul senator from kentucky he
questioned uh fouchy i'm sorry to have
to show you fauci again it's only 30
seconds or so don't worry but he
questioned fauci on the evidence that we
should be jabbing babies with their
experimental stuff
dr fauci the government recommends
everybody take a booster over age five
are you aware of any studies that show
reduction in hospitalization or death
for children who take a booster
right now there's not enough data that
has been accumulated senator paul
to indicate that that's the case there
are no studies and americans should all
know this there are no studies on
children showing a reduction in
hospitalization or death with taking a
booster
no studies no studies i know we cut the
video there but anthony fauci did not
argue against that there are no studies
that prove this but the entire
mainstream machine is now very into this
idea that babies should get jabbed
here's a little bit of a video that i
saw yesterday from reuters about babies
getting jabbed
[Music]
[Music]
she was born
at 25 weeks so she's premature
um so um the last two years we spend a
lot of time in the hospital um
but since she's been home we've spent a
lot of time at home
and away from family and friends
to keep her safe
[Music]
when we're going to canada
in three weeks for a big family reunion
so
that should be a lot a lot less
stressful given that she's got some more
protection now
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm actually kind of sorry that we
showed you that it's that's it's gut
wrenching like these parents that are so
brainwashed we're going to canada so now
she's got more protection you have no
idea what you just injected with that
kid with and not only do you not know
it hasn't been studied there are no
clinical trials on all of this you've
waived all your rights to ever suing
them about any of this stuff
these people and i'm going to keep my
kid away and i'm going to keep wearing a
mask
there is a virus going around but it is
not covet at this point uh it is a
mental virus related to covid that is
actually
far
far worse but fortunately guys there are
places in america believe it or not
where freedom and sanity prevails i live
in one of those places uh florida of
course with our not only our fantastic
governor uh but our
surgeon general uh dr joseph a lattipo
and i've mentioned him on the show many
times and if he was a democrat you would
know him because he happens to be a
young black guy
but because he is working for a
republican administration i actually
don't even know his politics really i
can glean
the idea that he like you know he's sort
of libertarian and that he doesn't want
the government doing everything but i
don't know that he considers himself a
republican but he is our surgeon general
here came in in the middle of kovid and
florida has flourished because of it
here was his uh tweet a couple days ago
on what's going on with these babies did
the covid 19 vaccine trials for kids
under five show a reduction in severe
illness did the trials show a benefit
for those with a prior covet 19
infection is there a benefit for kids
with no pre-existing conditions florida
puts data over ideology that's not going
to change
pretty good
pretty good there's no evidence for any
of this and these people they think
they're doing something good
i don't know what you do with that i
don't know how you deprogram these
people from the cult of kovid the cult
that the machine has forced onto them
i'm going to canada i'm going to see my
family member so i just injected my baby
with some [ __ ] i have no idea what that
is
um but here's another one we got this
from the herald sun if you think this
thing's not over this is what i keep
telling you guys it's like man they've
got this now they've got covet in their
back pocket that's how kovit is going to
work going forward and when [ __ ] gets
too hot when too many of us are looking
at reality and seeing it clean and
clearly they're just gonna pull out the
covid card and that's what they're gonna
do that's why it hasn't gone away that's
why a certain amount of people are still
so obsessed with it this is from the
herald sun in australia look at this
this is today i just saw this today
giving your co-workers and family
members the silent treatment and texting
not talking could be the key to getting
the covid pandemic under control here's
why and then of course they link to this
thing speaking for just four words
speaking just four words an hour
increases the spread of coven 19 10
times more than breathing normally
well i have to tell you guys there's
four of us in a relatively small studio
here and i've been talking this entire
time if you get out of here alive it'll
be a freaking miracle phoenix is
literally coughing right now
but trust me
if you if you think i'm making this all
up don't listen to me right don't listen
to me what am i who am i again i'm a guy
with a jacket with some hairspray and a
sharpie don't listen to me about any of
this stuff listen to joe
biden
mr president are you
confident you have i know you looking
for more money from congress for
this vaccine campaign and for for covet
funding going into the fall
uh how much of the supply of vaccines
for these small children
uh is there and and how
many of the nation's kids will you be
able to get vaccinated before you need
more money from congress well we'll get
through at least this year we do need
more money but we don't just need more
money for vaccines for children
eventually we need more money to plan
for the second pandemic there's going to
be another pandemic we have to think
ahead
and that's not something the last outfit
did very well that's something we've
been doing for fairly well that's why we
need the money
oh
did you guys hear that uh second
pandemic yeah it's coming i don't know
how he knows that now i get it
kovit will continue to morph
and we'll get these variants and all of
this stuff and we had omicron after
delta and omega and whatever and you
know they'll change and usually they
become less lethal even though the
original version of kovid was far less
lethal than they were scaring us with
way back when but he knows that it's
coming and what does he need well he
needs more yo money you gotta get him
some money so not only can he vaccinate
the children even though there's no
evidence that the children should be
vaccinated but he needs money to do
other things because in the fall it's
coming back and of course he then said
that he's done better than the previous
administration even though far more
people have died of covid under uh
joseph r biden the elderly man
pretending to be president than donald
trump can i get the numbers on that how
many died under trump i think it was
around 200 000 if i'm not mistaken and
how many have died under uh joe biden
because let's let's get that let's
figure that out and uh just in case in
case you missed it here's just a small
small snippet of what i just showed you
to really drive home the point it's
coming back baby
we need more money to plan for the
second pandemic there's going to be
another pandemic we have to think ahead
and that's not something the last outfit
did very well that's something we've
been doing for fairly well that's why we
need the money
they're bringing it back they are
bringing it back uh 400 000 people
died under trump uh related to covet so
i was off a little bit on that one i'm
doing some of this off the top of my
head and uh 600 000 died under biden and
they were they both roughly had you know
a year and a half of covet under each of
their administration so you know at 200
000 which is why i said that number
that's when joe biden sent out that
tweet saying that if 200 000 people died
he shouldn't be trump shouldn't be
president anymore well more people have
died yadda yadda you get it but what's
this all about it's about fear right
this is this is the distraction they
can't they can't distract you with good
things they can't be like oh look at all
the great things that are happening
right now guys everything's really
fantastic the economy is doing well
people have jobs everybody's happy hey
let's get out let's party they can't do
that they want virus number two and why
do they want virus number two so that
you will not look at your bank account
so you will not look at your 401 k
and so that they can basically blame
anything other than themselves for this
oncoming recession so elon musk who it
does look like he is going to get
twitter and he has become one of the
most outspoken critics of this
administration and he tweeted that he is
most likely gonna well he said he's
gonna vote for a republican going
forward but that he would support ron
desantis if he ran for president uh he's
now out there saying that yeah a
recession is on the way a recession is
inevitable at some point um
as to whether there is a recession in
the near term
um i think that is more likely than not
uh it certainly isn't it's not a
certainty but um
it appears more likely than us
personally i tend to trust elon musk
more than anyone who works for the
administration including this black
lesbian
right now we don't see a recession right
now that is not we're not in a recession
right now uh right now we're in a
transition where we will we are uh going
to go into a place of stable and steady
growth and that's going to be uh that's
that's going to be our focus
guys it's a transition
it's pride month and everybody's
transitioning so if you're not
transitioning from being a boy to a girl
at least we'll transition the economy
all right so look they're obviously
gonna use this as cover for the
recession so once the recession hits
they will say oh no it is because kovid
is back uh let's not forget that joe
biden just this is about two two and a
half months ago was blaming the pandemic
for inflation not printing all the money
that he was doing i want every american
to know that i'm taking inflation
very seriously and it's my top for
domestic priority
and i'm here today to talk about
solutions and there's going to be more
we're going to have to talk about as
well
but first i want us to be crystal clear
about the problem
there are two
leading causes of inflation we're seeing
today
the first cause of inflation is a once
in a century pandemic
not only did it shut down our global
economy it threw the supply chains and
demand completely out of whack
especially in countries where more
effective recovery
responses uh uh
weren't available
okay so it's not the printing of the
money it's not the lockdowns and all of
those things right it's the pandemic
itself right
it's not what they did in reaction to
the pandemic it's the pandemic itself
and of course putin is the other thing
right it's always putin in the pandemic
you give me a p word and it's a p word
man i'll tell you
um so this is they're telling us right
like they're they're the reason i'm
doing the show the way i'm doing it
today is because i want you guys to see
it as they're about to do it they're now
warning us part two is coming and
they're telling us that the first time
the economy was banged up was because of
covid1 so do you think they're going to
do this thing again of course here's joe
biden back in february talking about how
things are actually better but it's your
problem because you've got psychological
problems you freak
there's a phenomenal negative
psychological impact
that covet has had on the public
psyche
and so you have an awful lot of people
who are
uh notwithstanding the fact that uh
that things have gotten so much better
for them economically
uh that they are thinking but how do you
get up in the morning feeling happy
happy that everything's all right
deep breath dave
deep breath
guys um
there's been a mass psychological
problem so i actually will agree we
drove by on that i don't think it's the
psychological problem that he thinks it
is but there is a mass psychological
problem it's people that believe his
nonsense it's people that are still
buying into the covet stuff all it's all
the npc people and okay you get it all
on all of that uh but this idea that you
have so much more money that things are
so great but it's you have a
psychological condition you have some
you wake up and you're depressed and you
don't know why you have a little cartoon
cloud floating over your head and if
only you will take celexa or veletron or
some other drug which then of course
gives you the diarrhea and the bloating
and the thoughts of suicide and the
other stuff then you would realize that
joe biden is actually doing a hell of a
job
but
you know we must give the devil as due
and since they're telling us what
they're going to do how can we prepare
uh to be aware of it when they do it and
when are they going to do it well of
course a lot of this is going to drop
right before the election because this
is going to get us to a male and voting
situation and all of the craziness
around that but before i get to that
maya flores who is the young republican
latina woman who just flipped texas 34
red this is a texas border district that
had been democrat controlled for about a
hundred years and she just won elon musk
who was a recent texas [ __ ] transplant
he actually voted for her uh and she did
an interview on fox explaining why she
thinks she won
mira uh president biden won your
district by 13 points in 2020 uh your
husband is a border agent we talk about
the wide open border all the time is
this uh the the main issue for the
hispanic voter what can you tell us
about the hispanic voter and
what you're expecting in terms of votes
come november
well the main issue is inflation it's
the cost of living
everyone is
extremely pissed off angry at the
administration because of the increase
of gasoline of groceries of medication
that is hurting them tremendously
her name by the way is myra not maya so
i apologize because i think she's going
to be a huge political star and what's
she basically saying what's she
basically saying a district that went to
biden people are upset about the money
situation people are upset about the
economic situation of course they're
also upset about the border situation
over there they're watching you know
transients and all sorts of illegals
just jump over the border just flood
through the border and take over their
cities and then god only knows where
they go throughout the country but the
point is that that election i think is
going to be a real bellwether for what
happens what should happen uh in these
midterms that enough people are just
like you know what maybe the republicans
aren't all racist
maybe they're not all white supremacists
maybe they're not all homophobes and
bigots and they just don't really want
the government to do that much and by by
god uh gosh darn it
the government hasn't done a lot of
things well over the last couple years
and i'm gonna vote differently i'm gonna
vote for that white supremacist
republican party
so of course the democrats see this
coming so they need the virus and why
would they need the virus because the
virus
of course gets them to mail in
ballots just listen to joseph r biden
back in 2020.
it was a lesson in voting amid a virus
long lines and two and a half hour waits
in some places voters and poll workers
wearing masks and protective gear with
plexiglass between them i don't think
people should be voting today people die
democrats want states to expand early
absentee and mail-in voting have all the
experts both political parties and
academia laying out what would it take
to have voting by mail i'd much prefer
to have on you know in-person voting but
most republicans including president
trump
don't like the idea no it shouldn't be
mailed in you should vote at the booth
and you should have voter id
crazy voter id actually showing your
identification when you vote something i
did not have to do when i lived in the
dystopian nightmare of california i
actually showed my id i pulled out my id
to show it to the guy and he kind of
freaked out like no no we don't know
that all you have to say is a name and
an address so if you know your
neighbor's address you can vote as your
neighbor on top of the fact that michael
here who now lives in the free state of
florida and he's got a job and the whole
thing uh he got a mail-in ballot for a
california for the california election
uh just a couple weeks ago while he
lives in miami
you see what's going on here so the more
that they can push you to mail in
ballots the more the shenanigans can
happen and all of those things i'm not
saying that things are fully rigged i'm
just saying you can sort of see the
pieces right it's just about seeing the
pieces that are kind of floating around
right in front of you and that we should
be doing things to secure our elections
we've got a little bit more from rand
paul this is him last year talking to
democrat activist george stephanopoulos
who formerly worked for the bill clinton
white house who now runs abc news and
i'm sure he's very impartial when he
does that talking about what we can do
related to voting concerns
there were several states in which the
law was changed by the secretary of
state and not the state legislature to
me those are clearly unconstitutional
and i think there's there's still a
chance that those actually do finally
work their way up to the supreme court
courts traditionally and historically
don't like to hear election questions
but yes were there people who voted
twice whether dead people voted were
there illegal aliens who voted yes and
we should get to the bottom of it i'll
give you an example in my state when we
had a democrat secretary of state she
refused even under federal order to
purge the roles of illegal voters we got
a republican secretary of state and he
purged the role senator make a
difference in those times i have to stop
you there there no no no election is
perfect but there were 86 challenges
filed by president trump and his allies
in court all were dismissed
what i would suggest is that if we want
greater confidence in our elections and
75 percent of republicans agree with me
is that we do need to look at election
integrity and we do need to see if we
can uh restore confidence in the
elections
well 75 percent of republicans agree
with you because they were fed a big lie
by president trump and his supporters
who say the election was stolen why
can't you say well i think we're unified
in this one i think you make a mistake
hey george george
george where you make a mistake is that
people coming from the liberal side like
you you immediately say everything's a
lie instead of saying there are two
sides to everything historically what
would happen is if i said that i thought
there was fraud you would interview
someone else who said there wasn't but
now you insert yourself in the middle
and say the absolute fact is that
everything i'm saying is a lie
okay again this isn't to say the
election was stolen or wasn't stolen or
anything else but in essence what rand
paul is saying is hey we gotta do some
things to secure up the elections that a
huge percentage of people now look at
our election system and are going
something ain't right and it's like if
one side there is one side right now
things are not you know i know everyone
wants to say oh both sides are equally
evil or you know equally corrupt or
something like that if one side wants
you not to have ids to vote and if one
side really wants mail-in ballots and
and all of these drop boxes and all of
these things and the other side is
saying hey can we have roles that make
more sense where we can actually match
signatures show ideas etc etc like do
those things seem exactly equal to you
do they seem exactly equal to you of
course they're not exactly equal so
which side actually wants integrity and
which side feels that
maybe some shenanigans are more in order
to keep them in power because things are
going pretty poorly for them and let's
not forget of course first off this idea
that if you can't get that that somehow
black people i mean this is what they'll
always tell you this is what
progressives say if you if you force
people to have an id to vote you're
somehow racist because black people
can't get an id does anyone watching
this know a black person that cannot get
an id
when i had nikki haley on the show a
couple months back when she was governor
of south carolina there was this concern
that a certain amount of people couldn't
get uh voter ids they could not get a
driver's license or a government issued
id so she put money towards it a couple
hundred thousand towards anyone wants an
id we're gonna help you get it we'll
drive you there whatever we have to do
we'll bring it to you whatever we can do
she said it was something like 14 people
didn't have ids that wanted to vote it
does not exist the same people who will
tell you
that you shouldn't have to have an id to
vote well it's like should you have to
have an id to get on a plane we all
agree that that is obvious so is
american airlines and delta racist i
mean is that really i mean it's all so
stupid should you have to have an id to
go get a bottle of vodka
my libertarian audience would say no and
that would be just fine but that's not
what the progressives say they want
regulation about everything so they want
regulation and rules around everything
except when it comes to voting
do you think something odds happening
here so what can you do well we found
this video of you're not going to
believe it florida governor ron desantis
and this is a non-political answer
actually this is an answer that comes
from within because it's not about it's
not solely about the people who are
going to stand up and fight this month's
this monster and this evil today it's
about
raising the right people who will fix it
tomorrow what we really need in our
state and in our country uh in greater
quantities uh we need leadership uh we
need people that have some courage the
courage of your convictions and when you
stand up for the right things the way
our society is right now you got media
that's that's very dishonest about what
they do they have their agenda big tech
you got a lot of stuff you know they're
trying to always advance their narrative
i'd be very uh weary of any of those
narratives when they when they're uh
trying to shove it down your throat but
nevertheless that's just the reality so
when you're standing up on principle and
you're standing up for what's right man
people will come after you in this realm
i'm telling you that's just the reality
and it's not just people like me as
governor it's talking about people
parents going to school board meetings
it's talking about everything under the
sun involving uh the future of our
country uh you will face some opposition
for that so none of this is cost free um
but if people aren't willing to stand up
and and take those arrows and pay the
price uh to be able uh to do what's
right then we don't have much of a
future and so what i would tell you is
yes
understand government learn about all
this stuff very important but then as
you go out beyond where you are now uh
just be willing to have the fortitude
and the strength to stand up for what
you believe in
isn't that it
ain't that it and it's not just
politicians as he said it's not just
that we need governors and senators and
mayors to do it but that if we all did
it when your company
uh was telling you to go to a diversity
equity and inclusion meeting and you
said no this is neo-racism or whatever
it is in your life that you can do if
you just did it a little bit more as i
often say just a little bit more and
then it wouldn't be so bizarre when good
people stand up because there would be
more good people and by the way i would
show less clips of ron desantis because
there would be more good people standing
up
that's all it is and they will try to
destroy you i can't tell you the amount
of times that new york times or daily
beast or media matters or any of these
trash things have tried to take me out
or dox me or write horrible things about
me or all of those things i am still
here i'm actually better than ever and i
would say stronger than ever and clearer
and cleaner than ever in my thoughts and
my beliefs
that's all we need that really is all we
need
let's get some comments from uh the
locals community and the rumble
community pat says when the republicans
retake congress they're going to impeach
biden for felony hair sniffing
it is possible
you know it turns out that in the video
of him falling off the bike the other
day the reason he stopped was because
there was a little girl there waving to
him and he does love to sniff the hair
of young children this is just the thing
that joe biden is into there are many
many videos of it he likes the smell of
young children's hair
his government wants to inject young
children with things is there a
connection i don't know
amy says cdc equals center of dystopian
control oh i like that amy we're going
to use that one phoenix write it down
the center of dystopian control center
for dystopian control perhaps taton on
rumble says i'm getting married this
sunday well congratulations tatone on
rumble you know marriage
finding a life with somebody maybe
having some kids taking a little
responsibility stand it up with your
shoulders back there was some guy i used
to tour with who talked about some of
that stuff good things are on the
horizon very exciting uh this was a
solid show i didn't ask you guys how you
were feeling about the show before
but uh everyone's getting guacamole
today and we're not even having chipotle
we're having sushi but everyone's
getting guacamole on the side guys if
you want to play along during the show
join us at reubenreport.locals.com
part one of my interview with former
congressman now leading truth social all
about how to fight big tech uh devin
nunes is up on youtube believe it or not
it's still up on youtube and it's up on
rumble of course uh so you should check
it out there and finally a cold close
with joe biden and his mortal enemy
goodbye
he pours fuel on every single racist
fire you know who i am you know who he
is
you know his character you know my
character put both hands on top of the
wheel i am anxious to have this race